ja immer wieder schauen wir uns die
militärische Lage direkt an der Front an
in der Ukraine wie sonst Lage noch mal
an eben an der Front zwischen den
ukrainischen Gebieten und den hier rot
markierten russisch besetzten Gebieten
im Osten und im Süden des Landes doch
heute wollen wir uns mal das dahinter
ansehen nämlich das Gebiet um militool
mietepol eine Großstadt in der Region
die bereits nach wenigen Tagen im Ende
Februar direkt erobert wurde fast ohne
Kampf fast ohne Kampf bedeutet aber auch
die Ukrainer die dort sind die gegen die
Russen sind die sind immer noch da und
die sind als partizanen aktiv und haben
jetzt wieder zugeschlagen wir sehen uns
ein Video aus dem elitepool einfach über
einer Überwachungskamera und wir achten
Mal hier hinten drauf das Video ist
gestern entstanden und wir sehen hier
ein dunkles Fahrzeug was vorbei fährt
und ein weißes was daneben steht und wir
bleiben einfach mal drauf und sehen wie
jetzt eine mächtige Explosion das ganze
hier ja erfüllt das sind äh an sich
erstmal schlimmer Aufnahmen natürlich
denn wir haben es hier tatsächlich mit
einer Autobombe zu tun eine Autobombe
die von den Ukrainern gezündet wurde und
wir sehen uns jetzt an wie das dann
danach aussieht der weiße Lader den wir
eben noch hier vollkommen verschwunden
das Haus hier ist sehr beschädigt es ist
aber nicht irgendein Haus sondern das
ist das Haus eines von Russland
eingesendet eingerichteten
propaganda-senders zart TV also dieses
zart TV hier von dem Kreml direkt
eingerichtet um die Leute eben ja mit
Gehirnwäsche immer weiter weich zu
kriegen und prokreme zu kriegen die
Ukrainer haben diesen Sender jetzt
angegriffen fünf Verletzte gab es
Angestellte dieses Propaganda sind das
ukrainische Angestellte die aber im für
Russland arbeiten und deshalb in der
Ukraine als Feinde gesehen werden
wir gehen zurück zur Front und schauen
uns dieses Fahrzeug einmal an einen
Stolz der russischen Armee der Taifun
Casa 2014 hergestellt 120 russische
Unternehmen haben zusammengearbeitet und
wir sehen hier das ist bei der armya
2016 bei der großen Ausstellung wurde er
gezeigt und auch der wird natürlich in
der Ukraine eingesetzt und die Ukrainer
zeigen aber mit ihrem neuen Video hier
nämlich von einer Drohne dass dieses
hightech-fahrzeug 2 Millionen Euro
kostet das in der Produktion genauso
leicht eben von ihren Drohnen und von
ihrer die präzisionsartillerie zu
zerstören ist wie alle anderen Fahrzeuge
wir sehen jetzt hier einfach mal in den
Wald rein und jetzt sind wir ganz nah
dran wenn es noch mal kurz einkreisen
und wir sehen hier den Taifun K der ja
eben noch auf einer großen Parade jetzt
sich versteckt im Wald aber eben umsonst
versteckt die ukrainische Artillerie
schlägt hier weiter zu und wir sehen
auch vor allem dass die Soldaten
vielleicht sehen was hier wegrennen also
eben nicht ihr ihre mega Fahrzeug dort
im Millionen Fahrzeug als Schutz
benutzen sondern sich so weit wie
möglich davon entfernen in den Wald
rennen woanders weil sie eben Angst
haben weil sie merken dass sie erst spät
wurden dass sie Angst haben in der Nähe
dieses Fahrzeuges auch zum Ziel zu
werden dort sehen wir die Ukrainer die
wegrennen möglichst weit weg von ihrem
Fahrzeug und jetzt sehen wir uns an wie
so ein Teil von K aussieht nachdem er
eben von der ukrainischen Artillerie
getroffen wurde das ist nicht derselbe
das ist schon einige Wochen alt diese
Material aber so etwa sieht dieses 2
Millionen Euro Fahrzeug aus nachdem es
eben in der Ukraine im Einsatz war und
nachdem es dann in der dementsprechend
nicht mehr funktionsfähig ist als
letztes wollen wir uns noch einmal
ansehen was CSU Greiner dann macht mit
ihrer Luftwaffe wir wissen dass die
Luftwaffe der Ukraine angeblich ja schon
seit März zerstört ist in der
Wirklichkeit sehen wir sie hier weiter
in Aktion und wir sehnen sehen zwei Mi 8
Hubschraubern Mi 8 auch davon wurden
viele zerstört doch die Amerikaner haben
den Ukrainer mehr als 20 davon geliefert
20 Stück die eigentlich für Afghanistan
bestimmt waren die afghanische Armee wir
wissen es hat ganz im Gegensatz zur
ukrainischen armeekapituliert vor den
Taliban und braucht die seitdem nicht
mehr und wir sehen hier diese spezielle
Taktik nämlich die Katapult Taktik das
heißt der Hubschrauber fliegt sehr tief
an und schießt seine Raketen dann nach
oben ab um eben den Gegner damit
anzugreifen wir sehen das hier die
Ukrainer nutzen ihre Hubschrauber als so
eine Art Raketenwerfer sowie die Russen
viele Raketenwerfer haben haben ihm die
Ukrainer diese Hubschrauber und wir
sehen danach sehr gefährliches Manöver
der muss sofort abdrehen zur Seite damit
der eben nicht von der Luftabwehr der
Russen getroffen wird das also nur einer
von mindestens 20 im weiter aktiven Mi 8
der Ukraine die eben den Luftraum und
auch wir haben es gesehen den Boden des
Landes weiter verteidigen
[Musik]